people can see my non douchey features I
don't have big muscles or cool douchey
hair or deep v-necks oh god oh yeah yes
give it to me so soft yeah no judo throw
won't be faithful later here comes the
creep applier holla boy but stop doing
that no stop Jesus sob please dear God
Rosy's oh geez oh gosh you have the
homing shots I used to have that but
then I took an arrow to the knee for my
baby you know where I said that but was
there anything else in here that was a
new thing I remember sniper
crossbow Oh
oh my god see that in an instant replay
does that mean that you're a vampire or
not looking in a mirror and it's
actually a window yes okay I'm really
worried over damn it oh you brought
something home hi that's rude she's a
lovely lady you douche how could you
you'd be so oh my god oh man if I could
only imagine what's going on in your
brain right now well I can't imagine it
looks a lot like this yeah yeah
all right what did I show you last time
my tip penis don't don't make noises
like that I'm trying to concentrate
shut up this game is fun in a bit you
did a good job
hi finally ah like we just ba no no like
like [ __ ] what no high five as long
as I get this bass beat bankin beast
bass Spanky music open space there is
nothing I like more than space and if
there was a program for volunteers to go
in the space with like a hundred percent
chance of dying from death by space I
would be first in line to go to space if
there was a mission to colonize Mars and
they needed brave volunteers or stupid
volunteers I would be there so fast I
would abandon everything on earth to go
into space and I would love it I would
love every struggle of it I would love
the horror and entirely my numbing ly
terrible experience that it may or may
not be with certain death on the horizon
just for a chance to go into space
I should be getting sleep two rows by
John thanks for watching all of the
videos in this compilation are available
in the description so check them out and
if you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more under daily bases please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
thread thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye